this is the fourth and final lecture uh
nietzsche's great early work the birth
of tragedy
in this lecture i'm going to sum up very
quickly
where we've been and what the importance
of this work is why we're
looking at it so closely
why it deserves four hours of lecture
and then we're going to look at the
ending chapters of the work doing a
little bit of backtrack to one chapter
that we did skip over chapter 16 which
is very important
so
where have we gone so far well we've had
three lectures so far the first one
talked about
the very notions of the apollonian and
dionysiak as forces as responses to the
problem of life
and
we showed that
they're opposed to each other but they
can come together
also in a confluence
then in the second lecture we looked at
greek art and poetry and music and then
leading up to
tragedy and sophocles and nationalists
specifically before we get to euripides
and we saw how the apollonian and the
dnscn through a kind of dialectic become
more and more intertwined and bring out
the potentiality in each of them more
and more
in the third lecture
we looked at a third type of response
that eventually supplants the tunisia
and with at the apollonian
nietzsche calls this the socratic or
alexandrian response
he ties us together with western culture
in general
perhaps not all of it but but much of it
and he views it as the scientific
point of view the scientific project
he sees it as tied in with a kind of
metaphysical optimism that's missing in
tragedy
also a kind of superficiality
and so we looked at the eclipse of
tragedy in its last great
playwright euripides and then
degenerating into the new tragedy new
comedy and platonic dialogues and then
going even further after that so where
are we now well um
we're
we're looking at
the situation in a couple different
historical points we're looking at what
happened after
socrates and euripides uh going all the
way up to for nietzsche nietzsche's
present moment which is
the middle 1800s
you know western civilization has
engaged in quite a bit of progress
and we'll talk about that in a moment so
um
what's going on
with this replacement of the opulence
and the dnsc act by the socratic
alexandrian culture
something fundamental
that the greeks had found a way for not
just for one brief shining moment for at
least several decades
to make work to make part of their their
lives to to reach a kind of pinnacle
that was in some ways not just an apex
but a plateau
something got lost
and replaced by
this this different
will to knowledge this quest
in the process
what ends up happening is myth ends up
disappearing and as
nietzsche says it turns into a feverish
search dissipating by itself and
pandemonium of myths and superstitions
collected at random so the the religious
or mythical
aspect at least for greek life ends up
degenerating into
this kind of eclecticism putting all
sorts of things together
the dionysiac survives through mystery
religions which we'll talk about in a
moment but it survives in a lower level
than it does in greek tragedy
or then was present in greek tragedy
now science in the way that
the greeks understood it
in the broader sense of a culture that's
alexandrian in that it's a culture of
scholarship of classification
of making everything clear
and also science in the modern sense
where it's very closely connected with
with the transformation of the world
through technology transformation of our
very beings
did that banish myth altogether no it
didn't banish it but it suppressed it
it brought it down to a level where it
couldn't do
what it originally
found itself meant to do
i don't want to say it was meant to do
as if they're for nietzsche there's some
sort of you know teleology some sort of
creator who designed myth for that i
want to say that myth myth
you know the people who work with it
found it able to do certain things and
that got lost in the process
and the question that nietzsche is
posing in these last
sections of the birth of tragedy
is this
and i'll read it to you directly from
the word no sense my just
summarizing it for you
always better to have nietzsche's words
than mine
so he asks um
whether
he says what concerns us here is the
question whether those powers to whose
influence greek tragedy succumbed
the socratic alexandria euripidea the
quest for knowledge the optimism
uh whether those powers
will maintain their ascendancy
permanently
thereby blocking for good the
renaissance of tragedy and the tragic
view
what's he what's he talking about there
he's asking a fundamental historical
question
and history not in the sense of dry dull
you know
chronicling of the past like you know if
you're a historian you know chronicling
as far from from dry adult but that's
when most people see it
he's talking about a history of presence
at his time
and and still for our time
was there a fundamental shift that took
place
in two two places
um
after the the greek tragedy developed
and you know
was replaced eventually by a facsimile
of tragedy as the platonic dialogue and
all these other genres and all this
other type of activity
and then in our own time you know going
from about the 1400s on
with the modern world
has something been
so established
that what took place in greek tragedy
could never break through again or is
that still a possibility
so he's asking a question what happened
back there
could that happen over here not in
exactly the same way it's not by just
reviving you know reading greek plays or
something like that but something
contemporary something equally vital
something that brings out
these
potentials
that have lie
that have laying dormant
for all this time um that's the question
there
so
he gives a challenge
uh this is towards
the middle part of the end he asks uh
he's waxing quite poetically says
indeed my friends believe with me in
this dionysian life and in the rebirth
of tragedy socratic man has run his
course
crown your heads with ivy seize the
thirst and do not be surprised if tiger
and panther lie down and press your feet
dare to lead the life of the tragic man
and you will be redeemed it has fallen
to your lot to lead the dionysiak
procession out of india into greece gird
yourselves for a severe conflict but
have faith in the thaumaturgy of your
god
so there's a horritory passage right and
there's a lot of imagery there that may
not make sense to you right away which
i'll i'll go over very quickly um
dionysus is associated in part with
india
as well as with greece and with trace
and other
regions like that
um
the thirst is is a implement that dnsa
dns carries and they carry in the
procession
the tiger and the panther are associated
with him as well so what does it say
dare to seize the
the opportunity that we have before us
to revive what it was that tragedy made
possible nietzsche thinks that his own
time
is at a unique moment and we'll look at
that precisely what that consists of a
bit later and we can think about whether
this applies to our own time as well
because we're you know distanced from
from this work by a number of years
but i think that it still speaks to us
about these same things
um
let's think now about the scientific or
socratic viewpoint
so
again what was this well this was that
viewpoint that everything could
ultimately be made sense of
there were certain maxims that were
associated with this like virtue is
knowledge only a life that's that's
inhabited or
oriented by knowledge
is really a happy life
it produced a transformation on the
stage and with other artistic forms of
what could actually be
possible a
flattening out of things
there were some new things that came
about
what's really characteristic of the
socratic
point of view
is that it's a commitment
to metaphysical optimism
it's a commitment to the idea
that not only can the universe as a
whole and including all of the you know
classic metaphysical problems what is
the human being or the soul
or the person
what is life with others
what is you know the
totality of the universe is there a god
what is god
and then the relations between all these
different things those can all be known
and not only can all those be known so
it's not purely contemplative
not only can all those be known
all of those can be changed for the
better all of those can be improved all
of those can be
in some way fixed including art like
tragedy
that's the socratic point of view
so
nietzsche thinks that modernity has
become socratic or alexandrian
and we can ask ourselves what about
prima germany what about say the middle
ages
he says something fairly interesting
but not particularly
illuminating
about that
he says we've approximated the same
conditions the same conditions as the
ancient greeks
ever since the alexandrian roman revival
of the 15th century after the long
contract so difficult to describe what
is that ancha
the entire
christian period at least for the west i
mean if we want to broaden this to world
more world historical things
we would have to include other
cultures and religions as well but
furniture is mainly it's mainly europe
that he has in mind
and this long entre
he says today we experience the same
extravagant thirst for knowledge the
same insatiable curiosity the same
drastic secularization secularization
is part of this vernicha the nomadic
wandering the greedy rush to alien
tables
the frivolous apotheosis of the present
or the stupefied negation of it and also
speculate cycly all under the
the aspect of the age like symptoms
pointing to a comparable lack in our own
culture which has also destroyed myth
so
you know a lot of scholars will talk
about the greek enlightenment
and we can talk about a european
enlightenment as well that has you know
certain moments obviously that if we
want to be very technical the british
and then scottish enlightenment are not
the same thing as the french or the
german but in broad strokes they are all
socratic as far as nietzsche is
concerned
so modernity has become like this
what else took place what are other
possibilities
he talks about this in contrasting a
little bit earlier
the greek way of approaching things
against the indian
and
roman way of approaching it he talks
about
you know the dionysiak
led the greeks through their wars with
this great power of persia led them
through making sense of things
gave a gave something to the heart and
soul of a nation as he says and he says
we know now that whenever a group has
been deeply touched by dionysian
emotions the release from the bonds of
individuality
results in indifference or even
hostility towards political instinct
towards
thinking about the life that we actually
share together and how should it be
structured and who should rule and why
on the other hand apollo the founder of
states is also the genius of the
principium individual
sorry i stumbled over that
my latin is not as good as it ought to
be
neither commonwealth nor patriotism can
subsist without an affirmation of
individuality
the only path from orgiastic rights for
a nation leads to buddhism which given
its desire for nirvana requires those
rare moments of perioxism that lift man
behind the beyond the confines of space
he's he's being kind of sloppy here in
equating you know all of india with
buddhism of course but you get the
general idea
nietzsche thinks that
with
this sort of
thing
one way of going is to withdraw from
politics from the
life of
asking what is the good
how should we live it out together
engaging in dispute and debate in
disputes
vying for power all that sort of stuff
he associates the the lack of that with
what he's calling the indian mentality
and whether that's fair or not i mean if
you read indian history you see it's you
know full of all sorts of dynastic
struggles and things like that but you
get the general idea it's divorced from
politics
that's one view the other view he calls
the roman view
and he says
a nation on the other hand in which the
political instance instincts hold
absolute sway so it's not a dionysian
nation
it's a nation in which something else is
going on
necessarily moves towards extreme
secularization of which the most
impressive but also most frightening
expression is the roman empire
and if you know your roman history
or even if you don't and you get it
through you know watching spartacus or
things like that you know that boy they
are they're always engaged in some sort
of struggle dispute there were all sorts
of conflicts you know just brewing
waiting to come to light in that that
society they were never as simple
as um the the lines on which they were
drawn it was never just the patricians
versus the plebeians or
or you know caesar versus
pompeii there are always all these other
factions and machinations going on
well that's neither abalone nor dns yet
either it's probably you could say more
apollonian than anything else it's not
definitely not
socratic
um but it's not the initiate
now he says place between india and rome
attempted to choose one solution or the
other to withdraw
or to
just fall into everything's politics
the greeks manage a classically pure
third moment of existence
they could not maintain it for long
themselves but for that very reason it
endures for all time
and he says something really interesting
here before we go into this beautiful
passage
of what is noblest on earth we cannot
reasonably expect that it have the
durable toughness of leather the
toughness for instance of the roman
national instinct is probably not one of
the necessary predicates of perfection
the things that are great the things
that actually reveal to us
the way things truly are as much of that
as we can stand
as much of that as we can make part of
ourselves and take in and respond to
they are not
lasting like stone or even so much like
like leather
you have to be careful with them
they're valuable but but they're also
[Music]
vulnerable
let's go on a little bit further now so
tragedy
has been banished from the world after
the time of socrates and euripides up
through the greek period
and also nature things in our own
contemporary modern world
meaning both
opponent and dionysian coming together
is this the case
does this have to be the case well
there's an opening that that's occurring
now he thinks remember now this is an
opening that's occurring more than 100
years ago
he says tragedy could only recover
when science has in certain respects
not necessarily going as far as it can
but go on to a certain point
where it becomes
not only consciously aware but anxious
about its own project about what it's
doing
so he talks about this um
he says
the dialectical drive towards knowledge
and scientific optimism has succeeded in
turning tragedy from its course so
there's a there's a conflict between
these two things
in which case tragedy could be reborn
only when science had at last been
pushed to its limits and faced with
those limits
been forced to renounce its claim
to universal validity so this is
something is important the
scientific this crab
[Applause]
view it starts out in optimism
[Applause]
where does it end
it goes through a kind of process of
awareness
let's say growing awareness
[Music]
becomes conscious of its limits and it
ends up in a kind of
[Applause]
pessimism
something very interesting has happened
here we'll talk more about that what was
this optimism about
the universe
can be
fully known
and
universe
can be made better
[Applause]
the the issue of that sort of progress
and knowledge they're they're very uh
closely interconnected how do you know
whether you've made the universe better
well that's that's a problem of
knowledge in certain respects isn't it
knowledge versus mere belief or hope or
assertion
as the scientific process goes on as
human beings
apply themselves to knowing more and
more about things
think about the progresses that were
made
throughout the early modern and the
middle modern period
we'll just take one example by itself
think about language the growing
sophistication of the understanding of
language itself language is
you know
such an important dimension of our being
that aristotle all the way back you know
in
the ancient greek period was saying
that's you know distinctive to us the
greeks actually you know said logos
reason and language
[Music]
but as we get to know language more
we become more conscious of just how
much of conditions the
process of knowledge the processes of
science the processes of discussion
we become aware that we're every
assertion that we make is not as
innocent
a statement of fact as we'd like to
believe that we're carrying out
evaluation and doing so he's one of the
nietzsche's great themes that he'll talk
about later on
so this is the socratic world
is it going to fall into this kind of
pessimism have we arrived at that point
has
science been pushed to its limits and
forced to renounce its claim to
universal validity
has it
found ways to expand itself even beyond
the way say hegel wanted to do or has it
now had to come up against these limits
and say
yeah we really can't know that much
about this very important part of human
life
let's look at a certain contrast our
modern world is socratic nietzsche says
in that it's it's
devoted to this notion of progress
so their whole modern world is caught up
in the net of alexandrian culture and
recognizes as it's ideal the man of
theory
equipped with the highest cognitive
powers working in the services services
science and whose archetype and
progenitor his socrates so far so good
sounds very very good
as if it can continue on forever
all our pedagogic devices are oriented
towards this ideal that's very important
to point out there all our pedagogical
devices at least at the time that
nature's writing and you know
these speaking very broad terms here are
oriented towards this ideal of
knowledge
nowadays we don't speak so much in terms
of knowledge we speak in terms of
student learning but
it's really about the same thing
any type of existence that deviates from
this model has a hard struggle that
lives at best on sufferance
it's a rather frightening thought that
for centuries the only form of educated
man to be found was a scholar even our
literary arts have been forced to
develop out-of-learned imitations
well
can this continue on
he says
you know
we should acknowledge that socratic
culture is rooted in an optimism which
believes itself omnipotent
now
if something comes along to challenge
that omnipotence
then we've got problems
and that's that's where we actually are
according to nietzsche according to many
other philosophers he talks about
socratic culture being shaken from two
sides
um it's it's begun to doubt its own
infallibility he says first from fear of
its own consequences
second because it's no longer as
confident of the salinity of its
foundation
as it becomes more and more self-aware
it
ends up in impessimism so
this drive for awareness this drive for
making everything conscious everything
lucid everything
clear
and for fixing it on the way which is in
you know inevitably tied up with that
eventually begins to become conscious of
the fact that it's a kind of an
arbitrary position to take it leaves
things out
it can't address its own
adequacy
and he says the man of theory having
come to dread the consequences of his
views no longer dares to commit himself
freely to the icy flood of existence but
runs nervously up and down the bank
we're no longer in the position of say
descartes
who at his time could be this bold
innovator and you know tearing away the
previous what he saw as value you know
valueless detritus of scholastic
theology and philosophy and beginning
anew with this bold project
the word that they often use to describe
the current they're talking about it in
french is artists
boldness audacity
we're no longer like descartes i mean we
can read descartes we can pretend oh
maybe everything's a dream and you know
isn't this fun and all that
but do we really have the courage
if we're a documentary's point of view
to carry this out
or do we hold back a bit
do we
just turn into a watcher as he says
he sees faust and gerda is exploring
this emptiness and i'm going to skip
over that i'm just going to mention that
because i want to save some time
there is one other thing that's very
important though nietzsche says
one thing should be remembered
alexandrian culture requires a slave
class for its continued existence
a slave class that
does not get to participate fully in
this this project doesn't get its fruits
and he says
in its optimism it denies the necessity
of such a class
so the culture itself
which is relying on a slave class and we
can understand slave in a number of
different ways
that's worth exploring in a different
video perhaps
denies the necessity of it there's
there's an instability there
and
says it courts disaster wants the effect
of its nice slogans concerning the
dignity of man in the dignity of labor
and war and thin
nothing can be more terrible than a
barbaric slave class that has learned to
view its existence as an injustice and
prepares to avenge not only its own
wrongs but those of previous generations
that's a danger that the
man of science the socratic individual
engaged in this whole process starts to
become aware of anxious
and it starts to
again hold them back
german idealism as as a philosophical
movement he says has shown that the
scientific view he has its limits
doesn't possess universal validity and
here he's thinking
mainly about kant and and schopenhauer
we'll come back to them in a moment
and he also talks uh about
our lack of myth
he says
man today
stripped of myth
myth provided us something
stripped of myth stands famished among
all his past and must dig frantically
for roots
the socratic person
the socratic project has torn out the
roots that were there because it wants
to put everything on the surface make
everything as clear as everything else
it wants to spread everything else
before it well that destroys roots and
living things
at least certain types of living things
cannot continue on living without roots
and they can't grow to respond to new
situations so he says
man today must dig frantically for roots
be among the most remote antiquities
what does our great historical hunger
signify are clutching about us of
countless other cultures our consuming
desire for knowledge if not the loss of
myth
of a mythic home of the mythic womb
let us ask ourselves whether a feverish
and frightening agitation is anything
but the greedy grasping for food of a
hungry man
so what he's saying here is
once you get over here there's a lot of
escapism
there's
[Applause]
resourcelessness
use a word that
mcintyre allister mcintyre uses
but which applies very well to nietzsche
you know the socratic man the socratic
person
has decried mentions in that the
socratic person has deprived him or
herself
of the very resources by which they
might deal with where it is that
socratic culture has taken them
that's one of the fundamental problems
that he's talking about so there is this
this opportunity for tragic culture to
revive
but there's an equal opportunity for um
things to fall from pessimism into
nihilism
into
a situation in which there are no true
values in which
nothing really matters
nietzsche is often accused of being a
nihilist and he doesn't use the word
nihilism in this this particular work
but you see him
glimpsing that as a definite possibility
and a danger that has to be addressed
and what can it be
done by
what can how can we do this
well by reviving tragedy
or something like it
before we get to how he does that i want
to talk a little bit about his
discussion about opera and poetry and
that sort of stuff which may seem a
little distant to us but try to
transpose it into the media of our own
time think about how superficial much of
our own artistic production is
what goes on in it
you know we have tragic comedies those
are probably the most common form of
movies they'll certainly sell the most
tickets besides the action degrees of
course and things like that
in part because nietzsche thinks there's
a kind of
demand
for happy endings for everything working
out that we
we get some sort of solace through art
there's not a lingering with the tragic
maybe in
actual music
there's a bit more of that
and in good movies there's more of that
too
but you have to try to transpose his
remarks about opera which i think many
of us can't relate to i know certainly i
can't get into something else so he
talks about
greek poetry in the nithya ram and tone
painting i'm going to skip over that
and that music is as he says made slave
to the appearances it turns out the way
that plato concedes
character portrayal in euripides and in
a lot of the poetry and
novels and things like that that are
coming about
is individualized in some cases sort of
hyper individualized so it's only really
about this character here and in other
cases it's reduced to mere type so
there's no depth and there's no
possibility of seeing something greater
in the individual than just the
individual
now the opera itself
what's going on there nietzsche thinks
that opera isn't really musical
in any real sense
it's not musical in a deep sense sure it
uses music
and i mean if you where do you hear of
probably you have to go to a classical
station usually classical music
but the opera is
taking music and subordinating it to the
plot and the characters
and you know cutting it up into little
pieces that are used for
expression
more than anything else
that by itself nietzsche doesn't like
but what he really doesn't like what
what really sets him off
is what he calls the hankering for the
the idol a belief in the existence of a
pure artistically sensitive man
later on he talks about this as
involving joy and eternal reunion
complacent delight
opera at least at a certain time had a
lot of characters who were you know very
happy bubbling
um you know and actually um
if you look at drama at the time you
have a lot of this sort of stuff too if
you look at artwork so this time you a
of like this
nietzsche is talking about these
pastoral scenes where you have these
innocent shepherds and they're out there
and
they're thinking about the highest
things culture hasn't yet corrupted them
they are mankind in its good state and
there's kind of a reaction against the
pessimism
of
some of medieval catholicism and a lot
of the protestant reformation this
view of humankind as as intrinsically
flawed
the idea you see this very strongly
reflected saying philosophers like
rousseau is there was originally a good
state
and it was culture itself that corrupted
us and made us you know bad introduce
all sorts of temptations
bad structures that make us dominate
each other or seek to dominate each
other
all of that
so opera represents this viewpoint that
human beings are essentially good
full of talent it provides an antidote
to pessimism because what you can do is
you can think about how nice everything
is in this picture
for a little while you can escape the
whatever crap life that you're stuck in
where things aren't like that and you
can think oh wouldn't it be wonderful if
everything could be like that
you know
so again
nietzsche is criticizing this for being
superficial for being
you might say soccer and sweet
and why is he doing that well he thinks
that there's more to reality than that
and so therefore if you're peddling this
kind of thing to people which they will
swallow up and they'll get used to and
they'll think that's real art
if you're peddling this kind of stuff to
people
you're depriving them of the opportunity
to really reflect
and to feel
and to connect themselves with something
deeper
so you're keeping them from having roots
if you want to use that metaphor
and he talks about a defective
understanding of the emotions i do want
to mention that passage because it's
particularly
good
he says that
the
audience and the the the artist in the
opera projects himself into a time of
passion produced to produce suffice to
produce songs and poems
as though mere emotion
had ever been able to create art
there is an idea of artwork as if you
know art is just expressing our our
emotions our feelings you gotta wait
till you have an emotional experience
then you try to you know translate that
into images or you know talk about the
lonely tree out there
in the middle of an island blah blah
blah blah blah
and you know there is something to that
but in nietzsche's view that that's
degenerate art
that's
not really art it's fallen away from
what art ought to be
he says there lies at the root of opera
fallacious conception of the artistic
process the idyllic belief that every
sensitive man is at bottom an artist
in keeping with this belief opera is the
expression of diligentism in our
dictating its rules with the cheerful
optimism of the theorists the idea is
you just put the stuff together the
right way and you will produce the right
responses
i would suspect that nietzsche
would look at for example soap opera as
a genre
as falling into that sort of thing
um
in part because of that that notion that
when you just sketch some characters and
jumble them together and you know now
you've got a piece of work that people
will consume and enjoy
um i think we could think of a lot of
other genres and uh specific instances
of art that would fit that
let's turn now to his discussion about
music
and about how we get out of this
particular cultural situation
in which we find ourselves
dominated by the socratic approach and
it's
degenerates
he thinks that music could revive myth
and tragedy
and by music he doesn't mean any music
whatsoever it's not like you know hey
rock and roll is going to save our lives
although interestingly
there is a very strong dionysiac
component to rock and
um especially during its history
if you look at
certain works you can see something very
similar to what he's talking about is
this apollonian administration coming
together
um
at the same time it always risks falling
into kind of a commercialized
superficiality as well
um
he's talking about contemporary german
music and by that he he's going back to
bach and he's going all the way forward
to the tobogner so it's all in the realm
of what we nowadays call classical but
you know if you know much about
classical music you also know that
there's huge divergences
among classical if you only turn it on
you have something with strings you know
in the background while you have a
romantic dinner or you know some
something quiet to go maybe go to sleep
then you miss out on this if you really
listen to bach
um and you really listen to beethoven
and you really listen to voger and then
you know there's others that we could go
on to from there
there's some very interesting impressive
and important things going on
in their music that you might not find
out you might not find going on in some
other
people's music as well
he is going to take
music
let me actually put this on the board as
well
he's going to see parallels
between
philosophy
music
um
to a certain extent drama i guess you
can also say in there
given that that vogner's operas are
dramatic
and also
interestingly enough
given that nature is usually seen as
being the great anti-christian
at this time he does see some
similarities some parallels going on
with religion
in philosophy
it's german idealism
[Applause]
uh in particular
um not hegel
not uh
not really shelling
um not ficta
there's sort of an optimistic side to
german idealism and then there's a more
pessimistic side he also is not
interested particularly in marx either
but i mean by then you're getting away
from
german idealism into german materialism
right but still dialectical
music and drama we're looking at black
beethoven
[Applause]
and with religion we're looking at
luther
and the reformation
and what is
trying all this together
[Applause]
the german spirit
which he says you don't want to identify
with the german nation the french have
too closely identified the french spirit
with the french nation
and that that produced some some
problems and getting away from the
socratic
uh emphasis the german spirit on the
other hand it helps too that you know at
the time that he's writing germany isn't
unified right um it's a one gigantic
whole
as it would be later on you know
more fully i mean a lot of the process
of conglomeration is going on
but the german nation as nation is still
very young and largely consists of
states you know the prussian state and
barbarian state being the most important
the german spirit he thinks can be
not necessarily like a reincarnation
or an imitation or a revival but
something very similar to the greek
[Applause]
spirit what is going on
um
well let's look at the the discussion
about contemporary
german music
in in chapter 19.
he talks about this as inaugurating a
new mode of existence
that's some pretty
strong words a new mode of existence
that has been lost for a long time
so he says
[Music]
that
here we go
um
if we've been
justified in suggesting a connection
between the disappearance of the dnac
spirit and the spectacular yet hitherto
unexplained degeneration of the greek
species with what high hopes must we
greet the auspicious signs of the
opposite development in our own era
namely the gradual reawakening through
these things of the dionysian spirit
out of the dynasty act recesses of the
german soul is from a power which has
nothing in common with the
presuppositions of socratic culture and
which that culture can neither explain
nor justify that's really interesting if
he's right then what's going on here
can't actually be made sense of by the
socratic
people so what we should expect is some
some dissonance between
those who are identifying with a
socratic and those who are embarking on
this adventure of a new thing
so he says
quite the contrary the culture sees it
as something to be dreaded and abhorred
something infinitely potent and hostile
i refer to german music in its mighty
course from bach to beethoven and from
beethoven to wagner how can the petty
intellectualism of our day deal with
this monster that has risen out of the
infinite deeps there is no formula to be
found in either the reservoir of
operatic filigree an arabesque or the
abacus of the fugue and contrapuncal
dialectics that will subdue this monster
make it stand on the liver interesting
that he says that
because the bach is particularly known
for the fugue and contrapoint right
so he doesn't have in mind just bach you
know as a feud writer as this you know
baroque person but bach as a writer of
religious music as a colleague i'm not a
musicologist but as a colleague of mine
uh richard hall pointed out to me when i
had to confer with him about these
passages he said there's so much more to
bach than what people typically listen
to you have to listen to the to the
masses you have to listen to
the um
the religious music
in order to get a sense of what
nietzsche is talking about here
he says amidst our degenerate culture of
music is the only pure and purifying
flame towards which in a way from which
all things move in a heracletian double
motion
and then he says let us recall
how the new german philosophy was
nourished from the same sources
how kant and schopenhauer succeeded in
destroying the complacent acquiescence
of intellectual socratic
socratism how by their labors and
infinitely more profound and serious
consideration of questions that ethics
and art was made possible
to what does this miraculous union
between german philosophy and music
point if not to a new mode of existence
whose precise nature we can only divine
with the eight of greek analogies
it's not going to be exactly the same as
the greek association of
bologna and dionysiak but something like
that is possible now that we're in the
eclipse
when we're in late modernity the eclipse
of the socratic alexandrian
you know reason as as
figuring everything out ferreting
everything out judging everything making
everything better as that era comes to a
close because of the failures in reason
that are being
brought to light by its own activity
he also does talk about the german
reformation of luther he talks about
that at a little bit less length
he
says
here we go
out of this subsoil
what's going on
grew the german reformation whose choral
music the future strains of german music
sounded for the first time so the
religious revival and and reformation is
leading to german music
for the first time luther's chorale so
inward courageous spiritual and tender
are like the first dinosaur cry from the
thicket at the approach of the spring so
what's going to happen it's not an exact
peril the religious part gets things
going and then the philosophy and music
continue the
project through
he also talks about
two fundamentally different kinds of
spectators i i'm going to
have to skip over some material in order
unfortunately to make this work so i'm
just going to refer you
to chapter 16 which
we can't go into as deeply as i'd like
to and i'll just read you one thing
before we talk about this this new kind
of spectator he's interested in
schopenhauer's views on music
schopenhauer didn't really go back to
the greeks he's developing his views on
music
through uh trying to apply kant's
philosophy rethink it also through some
meditation on
indian philosophy
and schopenhauer sees
music in its fullest sense as
fundamentally different from the other
arts
he says that music
has a different kind of universality not
the universality of the concept
or of abstraction
but one which has definiteness
he says the deep relation is nature the
deep relation which music bears to the
true nature of things
explains the fact that suitable music
played to any event or surrounding seems
to disclose to us as a revelatory power
any event or
its most secret meaning
and appears as the most accurate and
distinct commentary on it
music
nature thinks he's getting this from
schopenhauer
is not
imitative
like the other arts are
it expresses the will in a unique
and much more deep and powerful manner
now it has to seek out images in order
to make sense of this the dionysian
which is identified with music
has to have the apollonian in order to
really fully reach its potential but
we'll come to that in just a moment
let's talk now about these different
kinds of spectators
um
he talks about the responsive listener
versus the critic and he's got a very
interesting digression there about
aristotle's understanding of tragedy the
basic idea there is that aristotle
missed out on something that nietzsche
is kidding but let's look at how he
describes these two different kinds of
attitudes
he says together with tragedy the
aesthetic spectator the the spectator
who is seeing art for what it truly is
has been reborn
whose place in our theaters is
heretofore been taken by an odd quid pro
quo of partly moral and partly learned
pretentions the critic
so we have
the spectator the uh
spectator could be of the chorus the
greek chorus it could be what's going on
at this time and then we have the critic
in the sphere where the latter had as
being the critic everything was
artificial only painted with a semblance
of life
our audiences had hitherto consisted of
precisely this type of critic school boy
and student even the most naive female
spectator were unconsciously
preconditioned for such response by
education and journalism it's
interesting to see here nietzsche's
criticism of education and journalism as
producing a
superficial
inadequate
layered over aesthetic response he says
what has happened to art what has
happened to audiences
is that
a cult of what he calls ends has
has taken over
he calls this a perversion of the true
purposes of art what happened next was
always what happens when art becomes
adulterated a rapid deterioration of
these ads what are we using art for
that's a fundamental question
every artist ought to ask him or herself
that what is my art for and they ought
to ask themselves is my answer the right
answer because it's easy to come up with
an answer that just satisfies your
egotism or you feel like i'm special
because i'm an artist or you know
something like that in our culture right
you have to ask yourself what is art
truly for
he says a good example is the notion of
the stage is furthering the moral
advancement of the people some people
see art as primarily about a way of
transmitting moral
teachings but in a different form
a notion that was taken seriously in
schiller's day
as the critic gained ascendancy in
theater and concert the journalist in
the school room and the newspaper and
society these are all like signs of
things going downhill for nietzsche art
degenerated into the lowest kind of
amusement and aesthetic criticism into
the cement of a social group that was
vain distracted egotistic and totally
unoriginal
never has there been so much loose talk
about art and so little respect for it
now if you think about our time
and you think about the proliferation of
opportunities to engage in discussion of
art
very broadly understood as all the ways
in which we
express entertain
imitate
ranging from
mp3s
all the way to
reality shows
to great dramas
miniseries
pick all of these sorts of things that
you want and we have a much wider range
of art at our disposal than nietzsche
did
is the same thing going on
um are there you know is this the sort
of holy trinity of the journalists the
newspaper
uh and the critic
involved in theater and concert the
place where things are taking place
the school room where people are being
educated about what to enjoy
and society much of our society now is
carried out through the internet if you
know you want to find out whether a band
is good or not
look at the reviews on pandora or on
itunes or something like that
ask yourself whether what nietzsche is
going uh telling you that has continued
to go on
has it to generate it down to mere
entertainment
does the very concept of art that would
have higher ends
make people laugh
what would those higher ends be
would they be the higher ends just to
say
preaching morality for nature that would
be a mistake
um
how can you tell what kind of spectator
you are
he actually gives you a test
he says
if one wants to try whether he's such a
spectator whether he belongs rather to
the community of socratic men
he may ask himself honestly with what
emotion he responds to the miracle on
the stage whether he feels that his
historical sense trained to look
everywhere for strict psycho
psychological causation has been
outraged whether he admits the miracle
as a phenomenon that seems natural to
child minds but rather remote from
himself or whether he has some different
kind of response so
do you take a sort of contemplative
socratic
scientific
distancing oneself from the what's going
on
i would also say do you find it just
entertaining depending on the answer he
makes he will be able to tell whether he
has any understanding of myth
which being a concentrated image of the
world an emblem of appearance cannot
dispense with a miracle
if you actually can respond to things
nietzsche would say like
an echelon or sophocline play
or the equivalent in our time there are
movies that probably bring that sort of
thing across
or to you know wagner's tristan and his
old in opera or to a beethoven symphony
and you don't say well that's boring or
that's entertaining or i'm going to tell
you about the history of it and those
aren't your primary responses but you
identify with it and you become wrapped
up in it and you something happens with
you in it
then you have the possibility of being
this other kind of spectator the
spectator that's looked for by the
opaloid and the demonstration the
possibility of being part of this
growing in his view
great underground movement
that will
neither identify with the socratic
optimistic spirit nor with the you know
let's just be entertained kind of thing
nor with pessimism or negalism but with
something higher something greater
something that will be a revival of
greek tragedy
[Music]
one thing that i want to finish up by
mentioning with this
is the the role of musical dissonance
and the reason why i want to bring this
up
uh i'll show you in just a second he
says that musical dissonance reveals to
us the dns and if you think about the
role of dissonance it was just starting
to come into its own with vodka
it becomes much more important in later
music i mean if you think about somebody
like prokofiev or
shostakovich
these are people who really knew how to
make that work
has to be done by an expert just you
know making a bunch of notes together
does not count as the kind of dissonance
he's talking about he says in order to
understand the difficult phenomena of
dionysiac art directly we must attend to
the supreme significance of musical
dissonance the delight created by tragic
myth has the same origin as the delight
dissonance and music creates
the primal dynasiac delight experience
even in the presence of pain is the
source common to music and tragic myth
a little bit later
he'll say
when it comes to the
dissonance
if we could imagine an incarnation of
dissonance
what is man if not that
that dissonance in order to endure lives
would need a marvelous illusion to cover
it with a veil of beauty
this is
the dionysian and the aquilonium coming
together
what is man if not
ultimately dissidents the socratic view
on life
was to try to overcome that
to try to get rid of that
one might also simply try to embrace it
and say ah i'm going to be you know
completely dissonant
that's not what nietzsche is talking
about either
one might try to escape it there's all
sorts of types of escapism possible
that's not living the true authentic
life if we're going to meet you either a
fully authentic life is going to come
through
trying to actually
tie in with this current of the
apollonian and the dionysia act
it'll involve being either a different
kind of spectator or a different kind of
artist a different kind of agent
within within culture and so here's
where we're going to actually end
talking about art and what it requires
he says
art is not an imitation of nature here
he means genuine art but it's
metaphysical supplements raised up
beside it in order in order to overcome
it
art has to reveal to us
what things really are
that's metaphysics
he has to be involved with metaphysics
but it has to also overcome it
it has to contribute something new to it
he also says this art must insist on
interpretations that are germane to its
essence
art
and the artist and the person
consuming art and responding to art
has to in our time become a bit more
self-conscious about what is going on
with us
interpretations that are germane to its
essence
he says at this point we must take a
leap into the metaphysics of art by
reiterating our early contention that
this world
can be justified only as an aesthetic
phenomenon
only tragic myth
only music
only tragedy itself
only the opponent is in the dnc and
being brought to a pinnacle not just
being separate not just being suppressed
only that can give us authentic
existence according to nietzsche in this
time of pessimism
nihilism escapism
and the you know what's left of the
socratic alexandrian drive for knowledge
so
again an early work of nietzsche
not all of the great themes that you're
going to find
in nature's thought are worked out
entirely this it's not what you would
expect of an early work is it but you
can see some of the great
ideas at least implicitly being thought
out the crisis in
western and european culture coming to a
close
the criticism of the socratic the
platonic
the scientific the drive for knowledge
the focus on what will actually provide
us with meaning
the notion that we may actually require
certain kinds of illusions but not all
illusions are created equal
these are all great themes
that we're going to see explored in
others of nietzsche's works
one other one you know the importance of
the
what's going on in germany at the time
about which nietzsche will have a rather
equivocal
point of view as things go on
so that brings to a close our
discussions of nietzsche's birth of
tragedy
and now we're going to look at
later
in some ways richer
more fully developed works